name of this talk which has just
disappeared is concatenate programming
from ivory to metal so what I want to
talk about is concatenate programming as
a paradigm what theoretical interesting
things about it there are and also how
you how you implement it on real
hardware what the advantages are
disadvantages and things I like about it
things I found interesting so Who am I
why why should you care what I have to
say I am known to some people as the
article of this as the author of this
article called why concatenate program
matters in which I failed to explain
exactly why Concannon of programming
matters but I did give sort of an
introduction to the paradigm similar to
what I'm gonna do today so you can check
that out I've worked in industry for
just a few years five years and my first
job in California was as a compiler
engineer I was writing a compiler from
ActionScript 3 to JavaScript in Haskell
and so I got familiar with what you have
to do in terms of programming language
engineering when you're working with
existing legacy systems and then we got
acquired by Facebook I worked on site
integrity infrastructure project that
you also may or may not have heard of
called hexyl which was with Simon
Marlowe we were working on spam
classification machine learning high
performance stuff in in Haskell and we
did a paper for ICF P and then I was at
xamarin and then we were acquired by
Microsoft where I was working on the
mono runtime which is a net
implementation and there I was working
on performance engineering and GC so
this is my background this is why this
is what I've been exposed to and why I
care about the things I care about
and over this this period of time I have
developed a list of things that I care
about in a programming language things
that I want
so for example because code is read much
more often than it's written and
modified much more often then it's
written from whole cloth
I want to prioritize languages that are
good for reading and modifying code
I want a language that's expressive and
what I mean by that concretely is the
syntax closely corresponds to the
semantics and also the semantics are
high very high level they let you say a
lot conceptually with very little code I
like languages that encourage good
practices and good is obviously very
subjective there are some broad broad
things on which people agree like
reusability refactor ability testability
and that kind of thing and I like
languages that make me do the things
that I want to do anyway and static
types are a good example of that where I
don't want to write type incorrect code
so having the compiler just tell me hey
you're doing this inconsistent thing is
convenient it makes me guided in the
right direction I like things that have
an obvious mapping to real Hardware
meaning for example when I write C code
I I can mentally compile it at no
optimization level and see you know how
they correspond how the the instructions
in the language correspond to the code
that's going to be generated more or
less right if if you did it if you did
it that way the generated code would not
be terrible right
obviously the compiler does a lot more I
like languages that are small and easy
to understand because that means that
it's easy to implement tools for them
right I can't write a C++ compiler I
can't do it I'm one person it is too
much right it's too complex of a
language it's too large of a language
there are too many edge cases and that
also means that it's hard for me to
write tools that work with C++ so if I
want to write some refactoring
application that operates on C++ code I
can't easily do that because it involves
writing all of the C+ put parsing and
like unless that stuff is available as a
library for example with Lib clang like
you really
it's very difficult to do whereas with
simpler languages I can just go and
freely do it right it doesn't feel as
daunting I like languages that are good
citizens meaning they interoperate well
with other languages either being able
to use libraries written in other
languages or being able to embed them
embed this this language in applications
written in other languages I like
languages that don't assume that they're
the world alright there are these
languages like managed code like Haskell
Java C sharp and even languages like C++
they assume that your application is
written in this language and you may
call out to other things but you're
generally not going to be embedding this
in other systems without first wrapping
it in some kind of C interface or like
it starts to get awkward they assume
that you know this is the language that
you're using so they're not very good
citizens in terms of cooperating with a
lot other languages so some notable
concatenative languages if you haven't
heard of any of these before fourth was
the first language that is now called
concatenative it didn't call itself that
at the time and as you may know it's a
stack-based low-level language untyped
essentially a high-level assembly and we
go through go through the 80s there was
there was PostScript which was
dynamically typed there was joy which
was the first language to call itself
concatenative where manfred von Thun the
guy who invented this this term
concatenative programming he was a
philosophy of professor at Latrobe
University in Australia and he wanted to
investigate how you how you do
philosophy when you you only have unary
predicate so ver
over certain things and he arrived
eventually at a programming language by
investigating this philosophical
application of combinatory logic and
from there in the early 2000s there was
factor which is a dynamically typed
object-oriented Concannon of language
cat which was the first statically typed
catnip language kitten which is a
project of mine which was designed to
essentially replace cat because no one
is working on that anymore
and there's also popper which is the the
first lazy Concannon of language so
these are the terms that I'll be talking
about and the the languages from from
which I'll be drawing examples so to
give you an idea of how we arrived at
this paradigm I'm going to go into just
very quick history so in the 1930s there
were these suddenly three formal systems
of computation that we arrived at lambda
calculus Turing machines and general
recursive functions lambda calculus
obviously you have variables functions
and applications of functions and a
couple of rules for how you rename
variables and how you substitute values
into expressions so you have this notion
of alpha equivalence and beta
equivalence where you can rewrite
expressions by substituting values into
variables and making sure that you avoid
name capture and things like that so
here's just a very complicated way to
write the identity function you have
Turing machines which are a more
operational way of talking about
computation and you basically describe
this machine that has a tape a read
ahead and a state-transition function
that can move the head and change
symbols on the tape and do that all that
kind of stuff and you have general
recursive functions which I honestly
don't know that much about but it's a
different angle mathematical angle and
all of these systems are equivalent
they're all Turing complete but it
hasn't been like a hundred years and
we've come up with nothing else new
isn't like there are no other formal
systems of computing
in the 1950s an important result was
combinatory logic just worked on by
Shawn Finkel and curry and in commerce
or logic the idea is you can do much
like what you do in lambda calculus but
you don't need all the variable binding
you don't need lambda abstraction you
just have Combinator's and applications
of Combinator's to other Combinator's so
it's it's functional programming with
only functions right and the basis of
this system are these two combinators s
and K s basically lets you apply a
function to an argument within some
environment and K lets you select one of
two arguments and from that you can
build all these other combinators like
the identity function these other
combinators like function composition
flipping and duplicating arguments and
things like that and here is look just a
quick proof that it's turning complete
you can express the Y Combinator the
famous Y Combinator so so with that bit
of history now I can tell you what
concatenate programming actually is and
I can just use the Wikipedia definition
because it's it's good enough
a concatenative language is a point free
computer programming language in which
all expressions denote functions and the
juxtaposition of expressions denotes
function composition so what does that
mean I'll just unpack it but basically
we we got imperative programming from
this operational model of computation of
Turing machines we got functional
programming from this abstract model of
computation lambda calculus and we got
concatenated programming indirectly from
combinatorial logic so it's related
equal in power but from a different
basis so what do I mean by a point free
computer programming language like well
you you know shell pipelines you
probably use them quite often shale
pipelines are based on composition of
programs so you have the output of one
program sent to the input of another and
so on and so on and you never talk about
names of the values that are flowing
between these programs it's just
standard input and standard output
similarly in functional languages you
often do point free programming when you
work with compositions of functions so
here for example as a function that
computes a histogram of the characters
in a string except for the whitespace
and there on the right is an example in
concatenative language it's very similar
to the Haskell code in which you also
are computing this histogram but note
that it's written in reverse order so
all of the operations are written from
left to right in the same sort of
pipeline style as you have with the
shell so what does what does point free
programming mean what is it about
basically in programming it means that
you have this dataflow style that uses
Combinator's to avoid referencing
variables or arguments of functions
you're combining behaviors purely the
term comes in directly from topology
geometry in which you try to do
reasoning about spaces without talking
about any specific set of points that
would make up that space in this case
the points refer to your variables and
your objects so the idea of the
advantage of point free programming is
that variables are go-to for data they
provide unstructured access to a value
you can take a value from anywhere and
copy it or bring it to wherever you want
which is very powerful and sometimes you
need that but we kind of accept it a
long time ago that structured
programming without goto is superior so
why not structured access to values as
well and the
is that if you follow this maximum of
name code not data then you often arrive
a code that is a simple and purely
functional representation of your
problem that expresses your intent point
free programming comes from this idea of
value level versus function level
programming so in John Backus is Turing
Award lecture here he presented this
paper can programming be liberated from
the von Neumann style so all of the
machines you use day to day are what are
called von Neumann machines in which you
have a CPU a store of memory and some
way of shuffling words of values between
those two and this is sort of a
bottleneck right like any any value that
you manipulate in the CPU has to be
either generated there or fetched from
memory or stored to memory and this this
gap between these two is only getting
greater and greater so we're trying to
work around this by adding layers of
caching and things like that but anyway
this is an example of value level
programming which you've probably seen a
bunch it computes the inner product of
two vectors and you can see that at each
step were operating using primitives on
a single value at a time right each of
these a high level so-called language
instructions corresponds to low level
CPU instructions and in order to reason
about this code this value level code
especially because it uses mutation we
need to mentally step through it right
we need to determine what it's actually
doing operationally in order to
understand what it's doing semantically
and that sucks basically because the
semantics of the program are closely
coupled to the state it's very low level
the compiler has to do all of these
inferences to actually optimize the code
for example to vectorize that loop
in order to debug it like if you've made
a mistake you have to either mentally
step through it or go through an ad
debug in a debugger everything is built
up from primitives like integers and
conditional jumps there are no
high-level ways of combining code and
this code doesn't have any useful
algebraic properties right I can't take
out any random expression from there and
put it in another function and have it
just work I have to write these wrapper
expressions that pass arguments along
and name values and essentially I can't
reason about any sub part of a function
without also understanding the context
which in an imperative language also
includes the entire history of every
variable so what Beck has proposed
instead was that we do a more function
oriented style of programming in which
we don't do things one single value at a
time we use high-level combining forms
to talk about operations over whole data
structures so he provided this
definition of inner product which is it
has a long form and an abbreviated form
but it essentially says fold with
addition so some composed with apply to
all with the product so that's map of a
product with transposition so the rough
equivalent of this in haskell if you're
more familiar with the language like
that would be some composed with map
product compose with transpose but the
idea that he presented was that if you
have a language like this you get
certain advantages namely if you have
the application of inner product to this
pair of vectors a colon is function
application in his language called F P
then you can reason about the program as
purely rewriting and substitution right
so you rewrite the composition to
application you apply a transposition
you apply the product you apply the sum
and you get a results
this has some advantages right it's
entirely stateless values have no
dependencies over time they only have
data dependencies between each other and
all of those data dependencies are
explicit they're written in the
combining form they use the composition
operator its high-level it expresses
what you want to do the compiler knows
the structure so it can optimize it well
the programmer can reason about what
they actually mean to say instead of how
to do it operationally it's made of only
combining primitive functions it has
useful algebraic properties for example
you can easily factor out sub
expressions so if I want to say like oh
I I have I want to take the sum of the
product of something else where I can
factor that out give it a name and
everywhere I use that composition I can
replace it with the name I don't need to
add any arguments I don't need to worry
about the structure of the program other
than just substitution so sub programs
are all pure functions which makes all
the context explicit and his ideas
inspired the APL family of languages
which I know are not terribly popular
but there's this language called J which
is derived from APL it doesn't use all
the old the funny characters but it is a
massive ASCII symbols but essentially
you can you can do the same thing that
he wrote in FP in in J where you have
this definition of inner product the at
colon is composition the plus slash and
star slash are the sum and product and
the vertical bar colon is transposition
so if you give it this pair of vectors
and you reason through the substitutions
you come out with the same result you
can in APL family languages actually
give proper names to things and make the
program's readable they don't for
various reasons they like the density of
it now but in summary it's a nice way of
working with code if you can
just build up your program from
combining primitive functions using
powerful combining tools and it enables
this reasoning that doesn't require
operationally going through your program
you can just substitute variables and
chug through the the substitution as the
reductions and you can reuse the math
that you've already learned before you
got into programming right like
substituting variables and operating on
expressions these are things that you've
already done for many years in
mathematics before a lot of people start
studying programming so the thing that
happened between concatenated
programming and combinatorial logic was
this related calculus called
concatenative calculus which was the the
main explanation of it was this article
called the theory of concatenate of
Combinator's by Brent Kirby and it's
essentially a version of combinatory
logic where you instead of application
of combinators to other Combinator's you
have composition and quotation is a sort
of it's sort of similar to lambda
abstraction where you can wrap something
up in a function and manipulate it so
the idea here is you have these basic
rules you have this basic set of
Combinator's that let you copy rearrange
delete wrap compose and unwrap values
and weirdly that's turning complete and
in fact there are smaller systems that
are smaller systems of combinators that
are that are also turing complete so
these these combinators like doop swap
drop quote catcalled all that forth
sounding code those correspond to the
the familiar combinators from
combinatory logic and
the interesting thing that the
interesting thing about this these
combinators is that yes they let you
apply functions but they also let you do
all of the things that you do when
you're manipulating proofs in logic so
you can reorder delete and duplicate
values and those correspond to what are
called sub structural rules in logic so
if you look on the right over there you
can consider the first argument of each
Combinator to be a continuation that you
pass on some values to after doing some
operation so composition means apply a
function passed the result on to a
continuation the the W Combinator is I
take an argument I pass two copies of
that onto the continuation things like
that and so it turns out that if you
give different subsets of these
combinators as your as your basis then
what you arrive at are different systems
in which are allowed to do different
things so if you just have B and I then
you get ordered linear lambda calculus
where every value have to has to be used
exactly once in the order that it was
introduced the curious thing about that
is that it works in any category if
you're familiar with category theory and
then you get these other systems as well
like whether you have to use a variable
exactly once at most ones for at least
ones and why that's important is why
these sub structural rules are important
is that there have been advances lately
in programming language research about
what are called sub structural type
systems and those has were present in
languages like rust which is probably
the most well known example also 80s and
clean soon haskell will have linear
types rust has were called affine types
which it uses to say if a mutable
reference exists to a value then it has
to be unique right and that rules out an
entire class of concurrency errors
because you have no way to do shared
mutation of a value
that can overlap so you have no data
races you can eliminate the overhead of
synchronizing your code in a lot of
cases substructure all type systems also
let you avoid garbage collection so you
can have these high-level functional
languages that don't require a GC you
can reason about not just memory but any
resource you can use these type systems
to enforce protocols so you know that
for example if you have a file once that
file is closed you want all operations
on that handle to failed so you can just
say well the closed operation consumes
the file and then because it's unique no
one else had a reference to it so it's
just gone no one can do it the invalid
thing it allows you to prevent invalid
state transitions in your programs and
it's got interesting applications in
things like reversible computing where
you can have extremely extremely low
powered devices in terms of energy
consumption if you have the restriction
that you never destroy information
because that increases entropy which is
usually released as heat and things like
quantum computing where when you observe
a value it it consumes it so you have
these this analogy between the sub
structural rules in Combinator logic and
in cognitive programming and then you
you realize that like continuations
aren't this like scary concept anymore
it's just whatever comes after this
current point in the program so wherever
I have this you know a dupe right I
replace it with two copies of whatever
value a is and I continue with the
continuation so and then operationally
when I want to save a continuation all I
need to do is save the state of the
stack in the instruction pointer
and I'm done right it's like it becomes
very easy to reason about what a
continuation is instead of saying you
know what this is this is too
complicated
so basically concatenative programming
is what you get when you combine
combinatorial logic with this
continuation passing style where you
like you can think about these these
operations these Combinator's as
operating on a stack or you can think
about them as being passed as arguments
as continuations to the one before it so
you can think about it either way and it
works either way if you're if you're
willing to turn your head inside have so
the other thing about concatenate
programming is all expressions denote
functions and putting an expression side
by side juxtaposition means function
composition so first of all what are we
composing functions of like what what
are we talking about what is our program
state and we need some data structure
where we can store values that we're
talking about and manipulating and as it
turns out most competitive languages
just use a stack where you push
arguments to a function onto the stack
they're consumed and then the results
are pushed onto the stack so you have
this chain of operations on a single
data structure so what do I mean by
everything denotes a function well this
is one of those everything is a
languages right we're in in like a pure
object-oriented language you have you
know everything it's an object in a pure
Lisp like language you might have
everything as a list here you have for
example literals are the they're
functions that just push a value onto
the stack so we tend to refer to two
things in kind of programming with
natural language terminology so literal
is a noun it's a value so something like
to write it takes
any stack it takes a stack it returns
that stack with an integer on top you
know something like a string returns a
string on top operators and functions
likewise they consume values from the
top of the stack they return values onto
the top of the stack and so we have this
differentiation between terms and values
where every term is a function but not
every value is a function we have real
things like integers and strings and
normal stuff that we like to work with
but we can also put put functions on the
stack right we can we can put these
blocks of code and then call them in
various ways with higher-order functions
and that's what gives you a lot of power
so the first competitive language was
forth
it was it was built around this concept
of you had you have these : definitions
so : means define a function
followed by the name and usually a
comment telling you what it does and it
just says to square a number you copy a
value and then multiply it by itself so
two squared we can reason about either
as an imperative sequence of operations
or as a composition of pure functions
all right we can reason about this as
substitution in a very high-level way or
we can reason about it as operational
code on a stack in a very low-level way
which is also very easy to translate
efficiently to hardware and the
advantage is you can write your code in
this beta flow style that often turns
out to be very readable in practice so
if I want to write a repple I can
literally say read eval print loop and
pipe the values that I need between
these functions and everything just
looks nice the problem arises when you
start trying to manipulate multiple
values on the stack at once right how do
you how do you do more than just this
trivial stuff and for that you often
have these stack shuffling combinators
like swap and
so here for example is a fourth
definition of max it returns the maximum
of two numbers so in order to do that
first it copies both of them tests which
one is lower if if they're in order
already
then we swap them and drop the the one
that was smaller otherwise we we know
that the one that was smaller is already
on top so we just drop it
but you don't want to do that all time
right you want to just get programming
done so in practice people use local
variables it can be more readable the
trade-off is that you lose some of the
advantages of purely compositional
programming so instead of writing this
is an example in Khitan instead of
writing duplicate these values and you
know if swap drop I can say like okay
just give me x and y from the stack and
if X is less than Y then Y is the max
otherwise X is like that let's you say
what you mean sometimes you do mean to
work with just values but the
interesting thing about locals is that
they're just lambdas in disguise right
we're composing them instead of applying
them but if we have we have a function
and we have an introduction of a local
variable followed by some other code
that uses that variable what that means
is we have a function that's taking the
stack we're taking the top element of
the stack and binding it to a variable
and then proceeding with some code on
the remainder of the stack so this this
hints that there's a very simple
translation from concatenative code to
lambda calculus which you can use to
compile it efficiently as well if you
want to have a functional sort of
oriented language and similarly nobody
actually programs in pure like raw
competitive calculus that would be like
programming and lambda calculus it's too
low-level it's inconvenient
you don't want to do it so akan Canada
programming language has a bunch of
syntactic sugar on top of that to make
programming actually convenient and has
different data types instant and so on
so like in fix operators right you don't
want to necessarily write every every
operator as a postfix function color you
want to be able to copy and paste math
expressions from other languages
similarly you want to be able to write
things you know basic straight line code
like if-else session session because you
can translate everything from infix to
postfix if you want but if you want to
start going and translating these local
variables to pure stack shuffling
Combinator's right unless you're very
familiar with doing that already some
people are some people who work with
fourth are it's not gonna be a good time
right you just want to be able to copy
the code and do the thing so this this
has one of the properties that I want in
a programming language right as a close
mapping from syntax to semantics the
data flow in the program matches the
order of stuff that I write in the
program and we have these interesting
these algebraic properties of programs
themselves and what they mean so they
form what's called a mono ID where we
have this associative operation of
concatenating programs and semantically
they also form a Mon I'm honored where
you have this associative operation of
composing the functions that those
programs mean so what that means is we
have a homomorphism from the syntax to
the semantics where the the empty
program is the identity function and if
you take if you take two programs and
compose them their meaning is the same
as if you take the meaning of both
programs and compose those alright so
you can freely interoperate between
these different levels of syntax and
semantics alright there's this tight
relationship there and count of
languages can be can have this property
at any level
it might be lexical we're like in 4th
and factor you can literally concatenate
any programs with it possibly with a
space between them but and and it should
work right we're like something like an
opening curly brace is a meaningful
function on its own in these languages
right so you can split a program at any
point or they can be competitive at the
term level where every expression
denotes a function but you can't
necessarily subdivide every expression
so kitten is like that so one of the
advantages of competitive languages is
being able to factor out any repetition
you want if you notice some some
repetition of some operations you can
always always abstract that out using
what's called factoring and that's why
there's a programming language called
factor which is a competitive language
so I took this example from the
concatenative dog wiki it's an example
of factoring in factor so in a C like
language if we wanted to get the price
of the top order of some customer then
we can just do that we can extract each
fields in turn and we can do the same
thing in factor weeds we say read the
orders fields get the first value read
the price fields but suddenly when any
of these things can become it can be
null our code becomes hairier right
certain languages have special built-in
operators to deal with what happens if
you know if things are no like a
question mark dot but they usually don't
abstract everything that way they don't
have like a question mark subscript so
in practice you need to do things like
this long so on the bottom is the
similar code in factor where we're
explicitly saying ok take the customer
copy the reference to it when it's not
null extract the orders and then proceed
with getting the first value from the
orders if it's not now getting the price
from the order if it's not known
but we have this repetitive pattern
right and we can factor it out we just
introduced a macro that says okay I have
this duplicate do a function when it's
true right when it's non null and I map
those over a series of functions so now
I can write this straight line code it
could actually even be written more
simply than this but there's just a
high-level example where now this code
have no repetition it just says what I
mean
right I'm getting the orders and getting
the first one I'm getting the price and
hey within that context any of those
things might fail so the basic value
propositions of concatenate programming
are pure functions are a pretty good
default unit of behavior for describing
what programs do function composition is
a good way of combining programs
juxtaposition just a single you know a
space is turns out to be a convenient
notation for that and having a simple
language with a strong mathematical
basis makes it easier to to develop
tools that are that we can have
confidence are correct and for also
humans to reason about their code time
okay so time to get into implementation
of these languages how do they actually
work on real hardware so in in fourth
typically what they do is what's called
threaded code where each each
instruction in the program is compiled
to a call instruction on the target
hardware or compiled to an address of a
subroutine and then you have an
interpretation loop that loads the
address jumps to that subroutine when
the subroutine is complete it jumps back
to the interpreter loop
so you're basically abusing the the call
instruction on the CPU for interpreter
dispatch and that works it's faster
generally than interpret than just
interpretation but you can do better if
you have more information so in fourth
the the stack is usually represented in
memory when implemented on on register
machines and so there you have a lot of
flexibility you can do dynamic
operations on the stack you can say this
question mark doop function says copy
the value if it's nonzero so you have
this it may or may not change the height
of the stack you have things like pick
which takes a number on top of the stack
and copies the nth item on the stack but
those are kind of frowned upon right you
want your code to have as much static
data flow structure as you can so you
can reason about it easily and so if you
have enough information about how many
arguments functions take and return and
if you have type information then you
can just do normal native compilation so
if even if you have functions like this
which are it's just an if-then-else
function it's right it's an if then else
expression but turned into a Combinator
that takes
it takes a couple of blocks and takes an
expression we we would need to compile
this differently based on the the stack
effects of the functions that we pass to
it right because those could have
different calling conventions they could
expect values in different registers or
return values in in different places so
we need like if we have enough type
information then we can generate those
specializations and we can just do
native compilation this is described in
the this this article by that's an ER
ttle who he it basically goes over
there's there's this spectrum of
representations between fully dynamic
and fully static you can either have the
stack in memory entirely you can have
the stack mostly in memory caching the
top value in register to reduce code
size and improve performance you can
cache a bunch of values in registers but
then you have to worry about what
arrangement the values are in when you
call functions so you have this finite
state machine of of possible calling
conventions for each function or you can
convert to one of the usual native
compilation techniques like single
static assignment static single
information and continuation passing
style whatever you prefer whatever your
compiler model is based on your language
and when you when you have enough
information to do that essentially the
stack is just a way of reasoning about
the program but it's not even an
implementation detail right it's just a
notational idea where you write your
program as this flattened data flow
graph but if you whether you stink what
do you whether you think about it as a
stack or not it does it doesn't matter
because it's not used as a stack
internally the restrictions on that are
you can't have dynamic stack operations
like copy if true you have to know
how many values things are consuming and
producing statically so that you can
generate specializations as well but
this just uses standard compilation
techniques right
standard registered register allocation
and the shuffling of items on the stack
if you represent that in memory you have
a lot of memory traffic but if you have
entirely static data flow structure and
that's stack shuffling is just
statically arranging the data flow graph
so at runtime it might be a move but
more likely than not it's just a no op
another source of implementation
techniques is a linear Lisp from the
early 90s linear Elisabeth variety of
Lisp where values are consumed when
they're used so variables are read once
it's based on linear logic and Henry
Baker describes how it can be compiled
efficiently to a stack machine
architecture and in particular one of
his ideas was to reduce this von Neumann
bottleneck of transferring values
between the CPU and memory by keeping as
much as possible in this top of stack
cache and he observed that this this
cache of values at the top of the stack
uses the space on the chip design and
the memory bandwidth to main memory
better than ordinary register and memory
machines von Neumann machines and the
interesting thing about it is that the
this this cache of values on top of the
stack is all live data as soon as
something is dropped it's gone it's
freed and part of the reason for that is
that he goes on to describe most people
say the the top of the fourth stack is a
set of locations where you can have
where you can store values but in
reality how you would implement it on
chip you you would never do it the same
way that you that you do on a register
machine you would just say okay I'm
going to connect the the ALU directly to
the top of the stack I don't need any
addressing to read or write to those
values and it also admits vectorization
and parallelization very easily you
could just say well I've got you know
add all these all these values I've got
multiplied I've got FFTs whatever did
you know signal processing operations
and those are hooked up directly to the
top of the stack which acts like a
register bank so you don't you don't
need to vectorize your code it's already
vectorized by the hardware so another
thing he observed was because the the
call rate in these programs is so high
right you factor everything into these
very small functions so you're
constantly calling functions you you
benefit a lot from inlining first of all
but also instead of using the call stack
to store the return address that you're
going to return to you can just dump the
contents of the function itself on the
return stack and use it as a queue of
the next operations that you're going to
do and if you represent that as a cyclic
shift register then what you get is this
interesting behavior at runtime where
you for small loops you're essentially
just rotating this register and
executing the operations in that buffer
you're never going and decoding
instructions from memory and then
jumping back and trying to do branch
prediction and stuff and then there are
the other implementation details
essentially depend on the language that
you want right you can you can box
values which gives you a uniform
representation it it makes it easy to
implement generic functions
you don't need to generate type based
specializations of things and you can do
separate compilation but the cons are
everything is in indirection everything
has reference semantics you need a
reference counting or a garbage
collection if you can generate cycles so
the interesting thing about unboxing
though is that it's easy as to do when
you have no types at all or very
detailed static types because with no
types at all you can just say well I'm
going to manipulate the stack directly
and with fully static types you can say
well I can do that safely and you can
unbox things like arrays and closures
you know you can put the elements
directly on the stack and you could say
hey well when I've when I've got an
array of four integers on the stack I
can always vectorize certain operations
on that especially if you ensure that
it's aligned so like I said this this
this vectorization instead of having to
incorporate it into your code it's
something that's inherent in the
structure that's available to the
compiler so it can do very good
optimizations
similarly with closures the vast
majority of closures in in typical
programs are passed down the call stack
they reference variables higher on the
call stack but they never they never
escape so you never need to allocate
anything so if you can unbox closures
that's that's a huge win for typical
functional programs so you just put the
closure itself on the stack with a
function pointer and then when you want
to call it you just coerce that and say
okay now the values that are on the
stack are just on the stack and I pop
the function pointer and jump and there
I go off to the races and if you can't
if you do have to box things you can
often get away with copy-on-write or
reference counting you don't need that
if you don't have mutation you can't
generate cycles so that always suffices
to reclaim all the garbage and you can
add GC on top
that if you want so are we I'm just
gonna quickly go over static types and
how they work in a concatenate language
most competitive languages are
dynamically types or untyped so dynamic
typing means there's there's some kind
of runtime type tag that describes how
operations work factor is is very
dynamic in a sort of small talky way
where everything is an object and
functions are actually messages on
objects PostScript you've got different
stacks for different types of values
fourth is is untyped in sort of the same
sense as an assembly language where you
can just freely reinterpret the the
values in memory as whatever you
whatever you choose and it's your
responsibility to get it right there
have been a handful of forth
implementations that have static type
checking but cat in 2006 was the first
container of language that actually had
a full static type inference but nobody
else was working on cat after a while
the website has gone away so I started
working on kitten a few years ago to
sort of fill the void and sort of the
first thing that you try when you're
doing static typing and concatenate
language is to just say okay well every
function takes some number of inputs and
it returns some number of outputs and I
can reason about the types in in terms
of just that but then you realize that
you can't do any polymorphism over how
many things there are how many things
you're talking about so instead of a
single call instruction that says hey
call this function and just do whatever
it does you have to have a whole family
of functions says okay I'm calling a
function with one input one output or I
wanted to put two outputs and so on
and that sucks so we don't do that well
if you I mean if you want to give a
static type to these operations right
and also fourth is generally not higher
order like so yeah but if you had a
higher order fourth where you you're
pushing functions onto the stack this
this call operator that that takes that
function and calls it on the remainder
of the stack how do you give a static
type to that it's like if you just say
well functions take some number of
inputs and some number of outputs and
you don't have any way of talking about
variable numbers of values not quite I'm
not quite sure we understand it took a
figure we can talk after so the the next
the next logical step and and what what
cat did and what kitten does is to
represent the stack as a product type
which is a chain of nested tuples and
then you can talk about being
polymorphic over the rest of the stack
so like dupe for example it takes a
stack of some type it takes a value of
some type and it returns that that same
stack with two copies of that value on
top right and for call you have a stack
an input stack and output stack if you
have an input stack with a closure that
tells you how to get from the input to
the output then you can get to the
output and one of the curious things
also about like examining kind of
programming that I found is that
all of the basic operators are related
to something that you do in logic or
with proof so the call operator is is
modus ponens right you if you have a
state and you have a proof that it
implies a new state in the form of a
closure then you can get to the new
state right and writing all of these
these stack variables in type signatures
all the time is super unwieldy you don't
want to do it all the time especially
because most functions don't need to
have this polymorphism over the stack
they just ignore it entirely and only
operate on a few inputs and outputs so
we can add some syntactic sugar and say
well if you're not doing anything very
interesting with the stack then we have
a way for you to elide these variables
but some of the challenges of doing this
are every single function is polymorphic
over the part of the stack that it
doesn't doesn't touch so that means that
when you pass a function to another
function it needs to be generic over the
stack there as well so here for example
with map you can't just say well it's
it's got some stack and the the function
that it takes also takes that stack
because you need to be able to call that
function that you're mapping over the
list on different states of the stack at
different times while you're mapping
over the list so you need this this
functional argument to map to be generic
as well which means that what you have
is a higher rank polymorphism higher
rank polymorphic function type
fortunately we can we can type check
this there's there's a great paper
complete and easy bi-directional type
checking for higher rank polymorphism
that goes over how to check these types
you can't do inference in the general
case but in practice what I do in kitten
is just have a single type signature per
function and then the entire body of the
function can be inferred which is
something that most people are willing
to accept
and do I was I going with this
oh yeah so in order to to actually
implement this one of the challenges is
that because you have this stack
polymorphism you need to be able to
generate specializations because when
you have you have a higher-order
function the that operates on the stack
somehow you need to know statically what
it's going to do in order to be able to
say okay well this function is consuming
a value and not returning anything
whereas this function is not consuming
anything but it's it's returning
something things like that
another finally I suppose is when you're
when you're reasoning about static types
most most languages don't have any way
of talking about side effects in terms
of a static type system Haskell is
probably the most popular counter
example where they said well okay we
have this pure functional programming
language but we can't do anything with
only pure functions like you can do
things but you can't do anything so do
you just give up and say well our
languages in pure a lot of languages do
high school solution was to use monads
where you say if I if I have some side
effecting action then I represent it as
a data structure and I say well the
runtime runs it right I am pure I just
build the value but the runtime runs the
value and then when you compile it
through some trickery and isomorphisms
you just say well I'm going to compile
it as straight-line imperative code
under the hood but one of the problems
with monads is that they don't compose
right so you can't always easily mix
different kinds of effects like I have
some state I have some reading from the
environment I have some non-determinism
and depending on the order or I have
some ability to fail and depending on
the order in which you compose those
things as monads using
transformers they might not work as you
expected they might be dependent on
order and one of the solutions that has
been developed in the Haskell community
is what are called algebraic effects
which turn out to lend themselves very
nicely to concatenate languages because
they're composable so in Khitan you have
this new line function which is prints a
new line and it requires this i/o
permission which just says I might have
different effects each time you call me
I'm not referentially transparent and
similarly you have when you when you
combine functions you get all the
effects of all the things that you might
call so if you have a function that
might print or it might fail then it
needs permission to both print and
failed assuming that you know print
requires i/o and fail requires fail so
like I said it's compositional if you
have a function that needs one
permission and another function that
needs another then their composition
needs both and this is a set of
permissions it's commutative doesn't
matter which order it goes in this was
inspired by a language from Microsoft
research called coca by Don Lyon and
it's also a higher order it's also
polymorphic so whereas in Haskell you
have this problem of you you have a pure
function that you can map over a list
but you can't I trying to say it if
you're mapping a pure function over a
list you use map if you're mapping an
impure function over a list you use a
monadic map map m and that's the case
for every single operation that might be
pure or it might be impure so even
though you can be polymorphic over which
effect you're using by being polymorphic
over some monad you can't be polymorphic
over whether you're using in effect
right unless you explicitly say I'm
using the null effect which is lame so
in this system you you can just have
this this permission variable which
might be left fully polymorphic and in
which case you can instantiate it to
know safely you can just default it to
know so this system of permissions can
enforce effects not only what a function
is allowed to do but also Co effects
what the function is what constraints a
function can impose on its environment
so for example constraints on what
platform or API version or something
you're running on and then you have a
handler that that runs the permission
and of course this can be used for
optimizations basically if I have you
know I map a function over a list I map
another function over list if if both
those functions are pure then I can fuse
those into a single pass whereas if they
have effects that don't commute like
printing to the screen then I can't do
that fusion so in summary the catechol
programming is something that I like and
think is cool and think that you should
think is cool it's it's simple its
elegant and it has a bunch of surprising
connections to all these deep areas of
computer science and I think it you know
it must mean something right so it's
cool because the in addition to being
elegant it also emits efficient
implementation not only on real hardware
but also you can devise hard
hypothetical hardware that's even better
for these languages it's it's immutable
to these exotic machines that we want to
talk about like Stuckart architectures
like the green arrays highly concurrent
processors or reversible and quantum
computers which we may see more of in
the future as we as we care about power
consumption and quantum computing
and and these languages are easy to use
right they're easy to reason about what
code does to modify code and refactor
programs and to write to write tools
that operate on programs with confidence
that they're correct and it as I as I
briefly explained it naturally supports
static typing and effect typing so if
you care about static types you can have
them and it's it's pretty good you can
do inference and things like that
hey I'm done
[Applause]
you